e se il demonio non è ancora incarnato
in questi capelli lo sarà in questo
videogioco bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono bravi
genio ci siamo su sony punto ex però è
la versione critico mario cera questo
doveva far paura ad uno tales ok io vado
mappa che bello ma perché tutti i giochi
krypi devono avere st musica schifosa di
sotto comunque lui ragazzi e la mia
preferito lui
il secondo è che knuckles vedo che è
morto un bel po di gente qua come il
mario però quale è morta un po di più
che si starà dire sony che ti fai vedere
o cosa continua così ma può neanche
cos'è sta roba
non sono per niente inorridito anzi sono
contento perché si stoppa tra musica
sonic sonic c'è qualcosa che vorresti
dirmi sonic c'è perché ha i capelli più
lunghi dei miei merda merda e loro hanno
parlalo vita dalle 20 si giochiamo a
indovina chi a nascondino va bene
nascondino odio perché piange devo
andare di qua va bene se non mi indicare
dove devo andare lo capisco
si chiama ricerca si è messo a piangere
queste leggermente più violenti
sei troppo lento vuoi provare ancora si
buon cuore stessa voce che aveva mia
mamma quando doveva andare a scuola la
mattina mi svegliavo così narcos ragazzi
prima con lui non mi ricordo se lui non
puoi correre a parte piazzi tua
che bello una congiura ma devo e posso
anche dare i pugni cape storia si
potreste non mettermi un interferenza
grazie grazie che mi cagate europee
ragazze col maestro potere a voi giovani
che si è posto a il maestro
sì mamma adesso mi sveglio arcavacata
cazzotti a cazzotti in bocca a velista
pagnottella arrivato da massa è stata
sotto i denti
io per andrei anche prove è fini che tra
può andare a mangiare effettivamente c'è
poco tempo da passare insieme ragazzi
miei siamo con l'ultimo personaggio di
oggi che il dottor non mi ricordo come
si chiama arma ok era il nemico di sony
che in realtà non mi ricordo come si
chiama nemico di sony non ho idea però
va bene
un po per lui c'è la sorte peggiore
dottor r trovarsi perché la corsa poco
poco eterosessuale che c'è anche belli
questi morì piastrati di maestro
che bello come corre bellissimo tutti
bene giocherei solo per prevedere la sua
corsa di continue ragazzi bellissimo
toni che farci vedere di così capace
neanche stavolta arca h
secondo me mi schianto prima io a
correre sulle scale che sonic sonic non
mi fa un pacchetto pura non mi uccide la
mia pena e correre all'infinito su delle
piastrelle veramente brutte ocado ocado
e rotolo perché sono una palla o non so
ragazzi sembra una fuochi bolso tiziana
poche molecole gambe però che
e che azzolini perché continua perché
non ci sono effetti sono la musica è
sparita quando sparisce la musica nei
giochi non è mai un buon segno ragazzi
vero sonic è scusato subito fratello
calma calma salmo tranquillo e quanto
durasse interferenza
questo sarebbe sonic 6 tutti io bella
stasera
io sono dio va bene abbiamo finito
chiamiamo il tecnico del televisore
permettono
no aspetta fermi nazione non a farmi il
fermi frena roba non ho capito come
cazzo
no non è possibile
come cazzo fa saprei io non e braga sono
scioccato come cazzo fa sapere il mio
nome non sono scioccato non è mai
successa una roba del genere in un gioco
cos'è sta roba in cinese
no ragazzi fermi tutti giuro su dio
vincendo su quel che cazzo volete che
non ho assolutamente messo il mio nome
da nessuna parte come fa sapere il mio
nome come fa a saperlo ma la ragazza non
capisco
ve lo giuro non l'ho inserito da nessuna
parte come fa sapere il mio nome mi sa
fare sony pd l'ha fatto pd paiono e
perché perché lui non gli scriventi
apparsa la scritta pd pie è apparsa solo
a me la scritta più di quanto non è
maturo su quello che volete che io non
ho messo il mio nome da nessuna parte da
nessuna parte come possibile lo avviato
e avete visto messo niente nulla
lo faccio alla veloce raga senza tagli
senza nulla così vedete che non metto
niente
niente non faccio nulla
[Musica]
sì dài ho capito sei bello è ok
io sono dio sa e per quello che sarà il
mio nome perché non me lo spiego
ci siamo era anche qui adesso non
apparirà la scritta
come falsa per i nomi come fa sapere il
mio nome non è possibile non ho messo
nulla non ho scritto niente come fa
sapere io sono fuori
comunque io raga vi giuro ve lo giuro e
il gioco pubblico l'ho scaricato da
gameloft che dove scarico i giochi di
solito non è non è il gioco di un fan
non è assolutamente il gioco di un fanno
vedete non so sono scioccato giuro non
capisco non capisco come faccia ho visto
di tutto e nel mondo faccio videogiochi
ho visto quelli che ti prendono possesso
del desktop politi scrivono le cose però
io non mi chiamo fa vj in questo
computer capito
mi chiamo lorenzo la cartella lorenzo
ostuni che l'unica qualche tratta non è
il nome del computer nome dell'utente
come falsa la tra l'altro anche scritto
giusto parigi senza la g staccata com'è
che riesce a scriverlo un gioco creepy e
non riuscendo a rischio anche i
giornalisti bunker haga sono scioccato
juno veramente scioccato non capisco non
capisco come sia possibile che sappia il
mio nome non vi giuro non capisco se
qualcuna delle teorie
scrivetemi le qui sotto perché vi prego
non capisco come sia possibile bei
ragazzi in cinque anni di videogiochi
non mi era ancora successa una roba del
genere una roba così krypi c'è da non
spiegarmi proprio cosa è successo però
va bene in cinque anni prima o poi
sarebbe dovuto succedere se qualcuno mi
spiega come sia possibile
fatemelo sapere perché sta roba è
geniale e jamie e da dire e tetra in
modo assurdo brown stesso tempo in
geniale perché mi chiamo è tratto più di
baila giocato è qui da noi non c'è
scritto niente la metà schito fa vj come
possibile ben i ragazzi spero che questo
video sia piaciuto condividetelo voi ei
vostri amici che magari non lo sanno la
spiegazione se voi non lo sapete perché
io non lo so non ne ho idea giuro cosa
dice che c'è un argomento mi piace anche
la risorsa come di tutto nelle tiziana
sociale c.fiscale che non ci riferiamo
al prossimo video per ragazzi
beh bella una sedia però va beh
[Musica]